part of the joy also dana is that we get
to talk about stories
that at times are wildly entertaining
and i cannot get enough of this story
about the vice president kamala harris
we played a clip of this on the show
yesterday before a detail leaked out
about
the context but this was the vice
president meeting with some children
talking about discovery and nasa and
outer space and she was talking to them
people are joking like she like had a
lot of edibles and they all hit her at
once she was really feeling herself in
this clip it's even more amazing to
watch which we can't do here on the
radio and the kids are dutifully sitting
there listening as she's rhapsodizing
about space and discovery or what have
you this is what it sounded like just as
a reminder cut three to think about so
much that's out there that we still have
to learn
like i love that i love that and so i'm
very excited about the space council
we're going to learn so much
as we increasingly i think are curious
and interested in the potential for
the discoveries and the work we can do
in space so
that's one of the things i'm most
excited about
and she goes on at one point i'm telling
it's gonna be
unbelievable you can see the moon with
your own
eyes and the kids are like whoa she's
talking to them like they're five
they look like they're maybe twelve or
13 so there's the awkwardness there
and then we learned last night
that these were not kids from some local
school that was my assumption like the
the science club from when the local dc
schools came in to learn about this and
it's a youtube
series called get curious with vice
president harris no these were actually
child actors who had to audition for
these parts and they booked these parts
to show up and play average kids which
is probably why they look so engaged and
enthralled as opposed to slightly
creeped out by this woman
i don't understand what the thought
process was here to have paid child
actors come in for this it makes it even
more hilarious to me dana i think that's
the thing that we should all do with
this we just you just have to laugh this
is
one of my very favorite shows of the
last several years is veep i recommend
it to everybody like this would have
happened on veep it literally would have
happened and then when the white house
um
responded today when the vice
president's office responded their
statement was something like we had no
idea that this was happening we had
nothing to do with the child actors
and i said oh don't worry
we didn't think you had a clue about any
of it i mean
that is a pattern that we are seeing
over and over again you know they hired
him they don't know anything they hired
an image consultant to help her seem
more relatable
and in order to do that they had to hire
child actors
and also guy do you know that this was
all happening she actually filmed this
on the day where afghanistan was falling
apart
it was that day i was i can't remember
the exact date but it was yeah it was
one of those days i'm trying to find it
in my notes right here um yeah it was
one of those like one like those days
where you're thinking oh my gosh did
this um you know you see everything uh
disintegrating kids getting kicked out
girls getting kicked out of school
things like that um wait here it is
right here it is right here bring the
actors in bring the kid actors in here
and they're going to uh ooh and ah as
the vice president talks about
outer space yep
yep um but here's the thing um
just laugh about it right so they use
taxpayer dollars but oh wait i forgot
the best part forgot the best part
yeah the name of the production company
i love this
sinking ship entertainment honestly this
is veep
even even the writers and they're
they're they're not come up with this
it's that fun they're not even american
they're not even an american people
toronto how about that
they're a canadian group america's
second ship america they brought these
kids in and there's one one of the child
actors who i think is 13
uh who
auditioned
and then his agent called him and said
hey you booked the gig and the gig was
to come and pretend to be interested
at the naval observatory with kamala
harris who's uh carrying on with these
children i guess
did you notice the other part of that
dana where
it's like she psyched herself up to talk
to kids and had
sort of a mismatch in her brain of the
tone
for the age group because you talk to
tweens or adolescents very differently
than first graders but she was going
first grader with the tweens i think
i saw some person for her has been for a
long time that she doesn't seem
authentic
um and you saw that in the focus don't
take that from me um
this is from democratic voters
um that there was an authenticity
problem and you saw this over and over
again
and they don't do her any favors
as an image consultant saying oh this
would might be a really great way to
make her seem relatable by hiring child
actors and putting her in a position
where she's not comfortable
so what do you get for for this they're
going to put this on a youtube channel
what voter exactly what voter
constituency are you going for what do
you actually care about do you know have
any idea what's going on in this country
um guy i have to say that i just find it
mystifying that somebody who achieves
this incredible accomplishment of
becoming the first woman vice president
is basically
not doing anything with the power of the
office
and i and and i don't i realize that a
lot of people might think
that whatever she would do on the border
might not be what they want but at least
you could admire her for trying
she literally is doing nothing
that you can see
there's nothing tangible and i think
what a waste of an opportunity
and i say that here publicly because i
would like to say to her in person like
come on
just do it like for example when those
three
guys in the biden administration went
down to mexico last week to talk about
the immigration problem
and she didn't go and she's supposed to
be in charge of the issue
there's no way i would have let them go
without me heck no i would have said
actually you guys are invited to ride on
my plane and i will be leading the
delegation and you can brief me while we
are on our way there
because the president put her in charge
of this that was biden's decision i
don't think she wants to be in charge of
it i think she'd much rather do this
with with get curious i have to note by
the way dana all upon it writing at hot
air had a very funny take on this entire
brokenness it is straight out of veep he
said you needed child actors because she
was acting so out there
in her conversation this this painfully
phony weird affect that normal school
kids would have been looking at each
other with side eye like uh what the
hell is this woman talking about so you
needed people who are really
professionals to pretend like everything
was normal and good and they did a very
good job and one of the kids was quoted
saying oh she's she's very charming
she's very charismatic and all opponents
said well he would have to say that if
he wants to land the role and get
curious too
the sequel from uh sinking ship
productions but dana you mentioned
the vice president not really asserting
herself on the border or really on
anything she seems to have been
sidelined by the president's team but
also self-sidelining in some ways
the president meanwhile
is not taking questions almost ever we
ran through some of the stats yesterday
the rnc
went back and looked at the tape he has
not taken a question on afghanistan in
32 days
he's done one sit-down interview as you
know when you put a principal in the
president or whomever down
and you sit them down for a one-on-one
interview
that interviewer that journalist has an
opportunity to really go back and forth
and dig deeper and and ask follow-ups he
has exposed himself or subjected himself
to that type of grilling
one time in the last almost three months
obviously this is a strategy that they
have decided on they've landed on it
saying i guess the president defending
himself and making his case would do
more harm and therefore we are going to
shield him from questions as often as
possible what do you make dana of that
strategy i think it's terrible i mean it
might they might think that it's helping
him but look at the poll numbers uh
they're in free fall
so it seems to me like the white house
is floundering and also what happened to
return to norms i thought we were
returning to norms
um
and the norms is that the president
takes
questions from the press president trump
took questions all the time
uh and even though the press
the mainstream media really couldn't
stand him they loved the fact that they
had access to him
and because they seem to try to treat
president biden with kid gloves they're
not complaining about no access
i have to tell you if i was white house
press secretary
i could imagine during the bush
administration if president bush didn't
take questions for this long on such an
important topic that is
of great national interest um i would
have heard about it from the white house
correspondent correspondents association
they would have been beating down my
door but also i would have wanted to
help provide that however i didn't
i just worked for a president who would
never would have put me in that position
right so as much as you think the staff
won't let him the staff won't let him
look he's in charge he is the
commander-in-chief he gets to decide and
deroy murdoch of national review had a
really good piece in which he said biden
is in charge like a lot many people
might think that everybody else is
running the show but that lets him off
too easily
yep he loves it he's making he used to
love to talk to the press he knows he
should talk to the press and that's why
he always says oh they told me not to
take questions
so that he can blame somebody else and
it's not just afghanistan it's the
border i mean there are multiple
concurrent crises he's presiding over
all of them and he deems to take a
question here or there every so often
with very few follow-ups he often snaps
at reporters who might shout a question
at him
it's not a great look to put it very
mildly but it is what they've landed on
as their their tactical footing moving
forward here and it isn't going well but
i guess their fear is it could go even
worse the more he talks and that's the
calculation apparently that they have
made thus far dana perino we've got to
let you go i know you're preparing for
the five coming up in just over an hour
on fox news channel we always love
chatting with you let's have you back
soon okay oh you bet bye guys our friend
dana perino and our colleague on the guy
benson show more right after this
you